This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。保证真人原创。嘿，大家近来都好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲出行。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，收听《以艰难的方式学习》
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名男同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是TWA%，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he does. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. This topic, today's episode and the theories and thoughts we're going to be
目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们。相信我，宝贝》（the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理。这个话题，今天的节目以及我们要
discussing. They have been massively inspired by a book I just finished reading that has completely changed my life. It is called The Courage to Be Disliked. This book is, including, credible. I truly recommend it. It basically teaches us what it means to live in total freedom, to become our best selves and actually live according to our wants, our purpose, our vision for life instead of being, I think, held back by the opinions and the expectations and the judgments of others. It made me take a very long, hard look at myself. And part of that was honestly assessing who am I actually living for these days? This philosophy, this idea that we can escape kind of our need to constantly impress others and worry about what they think is one that I believe
讨论的理论和想法。它们深受我刚刚读完的一本书的启发，那本书彻底改变了我的生活。它叫作《被讨厌的勇气》（The Courage to Be Disliked）。这本书，包括，太棒了。我真心推荐它。它基本上教导我们，作为一个完全自由的人意味着什么，如何成为最好的自己，并真正根据我们的愿望、我们的目标、我们对生活的愿景来生活，而不是被我认为是他人意见、期望和判断所束缚。它让我对自己进行了一次漫长而严厉的审视。而这其中一部分就是诚实地评估：这些日子里我究竟是为了谁而活？这种哲学，这种我们可以摆脱不断取悦他人、担心他们看法的需求的理念，是我坚信
a lot of us in our 20s really need to hear. We needed to be reminded of and embrace this deep belief that what others think of us is one of the least important things about who we are. That constant concern for other people manifests in a lot of anxiety for us. anxiety that creates self-judgment, self-sabotage, self-betrayal, and it's those reactions, that anxiety that informs our behavior. It causes us to act in certain ways. We want to conform. We want to be someone we're not. We want to say things that we don't believe. We feel uncomfortable in our skin. And I think this creates a real disconnect that we're seeing more and more between the version of you who is perceived by others and the version of you that is real,
我们很多二十岁的人真正需要听到的。我们需要被提醒并拥抱这种深厚的信念：别人怎么看我们，是我们身上最不重要的特征之一。对他人持续的关注会给我们带来大量的焦虑。这种焦虑会产生自我评判、自我破坏、自我背叛，而正是这些反应、这种焦虑塑造了我们的行为。它导致我们以特定的方式行事。我们想要顺从。我们想成为一个我们本不是的人。我们想说一些我们并不相信的话。我们在这个皮囊里感到很不自在。我认为这造成了一种真正的脱节，我们越来越多地看到这种脱节：被他人感知的那个版本的你，与真实的那个版本的你，
the version of you that you actually like. And I think by having the courage to be disliked, even if it's uncomfortable, we bring those two versions of us back together, the version that other people see and the version of us that is truthful. So today we're going to discuss this. We're going to discuss why having the courage and the power to not be liked by everyone might actually be the secret to greater emotional satisfaction and just a better life. So we're going to break down where our need to be liked comes from, particularly ideas of social approval, why we worry about silly ideas like reputation, what that results in, particularly conformity, alienation, a loss of self.
那个你真正喜欢的版本的你之间的脱节。我认为，通过拥有被讨厌的勇气，即使这让人感到不舒服，我们也能将这两个版本的自己重新结合起来——别人看到的版本和真实的那个版本。所以今天我们要讨论这个。我们要讨论为什么拥有不被所有人喜欢的勇气和力量，实际上可能是获得更大情感满足和更美好生活的秘密。因此，我们将剖析我们对被喜欢的需求的来源，特别是社会认同的概念，为什么我们要担心像声誉这样愚蠢的想法，这会导致什么结果，尤其是顺从、疏离和自我的丧失。
And I also want to discuss this idea that we have in Australia called Tall Puppie Syndrome, which really explains why society in general feels the need to tear down the brightest and the most authentic individuals in our society. Perhaps as a projection of our own individual and collective insecurities, we see that so many times the people who really choose to be themselves and choose to just do what they would like in life and really, really represent their true desires and just have the courage to do that are often the ones that receive the most criticism. And I want to understand kind of why is that the case. We're also going to
我还想讨论我们在澳大利亚称为“高罂粟综合症”（Tall Poppy Syndrome）的概念，这很好地解释了为什么整个社会都觉得有必要贬低我们社会中最聪明、最真实的人。这或许是我们个人和集体不安全感的一种投射，我们多次看到，那些真正选择做自己、选择只做自己在生活中想做的事、真正代表自己真实愿望并有勇气做到这一点的人，往往是受到最多批评的人。我想了解这背后的原因。我们还将
explore some of the consequences of what happens to us when we solely live for others, whether that's our family, our friends, our partners. What happens when we turn away from the pressure to impress other people. When we turn away from the pressure to be someone we're not, I think that that is such an important philosophy that we need to adopt during this decade. If you want to perform at your highest level, if you want to be the happiest version of yourself, often one of the biggest things that is holding us back is the opinions of others. So today, if you're needing a confidence boost, if you've recently been on the receiving end of someone's negative opinions, negative judgments of you, or if you just want to de-center the assumptions and views of others, this episode is for you.
探讨当我们完全为了他人而活时，会发生什么后果，无论是我们的家人、朋友还是伴侣。当我们不再承受取悦他人的压力时会发生什么。当我们不再承受去做一个并非真实的自己的压力时，我认为这是我们在这一十年中需要采纳的一项极其重要的哲学。如果你想发挥出最高水平，如果你想成为最快乐的自己，往往阻碍我们前进的最大因素之一就是别人的意见。所以今天，如果你需要提升自信，如果你最近承受了别人对你的负面意见、负面评价，或者如果你只是想把别人的假设和看法边缘化，这一集就是为你准备的。
So without further ado, let's jump into how we can embrace and live out our power to be disliked. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
废话不多说，让我们直接切入如何拥抱并践行我们被讨厌的力量。《2%》。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app,
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是TWO%，在iHeart Radio应用上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got? to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
苹果播客，或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟小金有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过那段时光的。其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆到了台面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
欢迎收听我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的心理治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines），在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》中，我们将就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的Our Heart Radio应用。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in soons, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
搜索《以艰难的方式学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才破了案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名男同性恋者，还有迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我的脑子都炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So there is this really powerful quote from Marcus Aurelius, this very famous Roman guy, and I think it captures our dislike of being disliked more than anything else I've ever heard. We all love ourselves more than other people, but we care more about their opinion than our own.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。所以，马克·奥勒留（Marcus Aurelius）——这位非常著名的罗马人——有一句非常有力的话，我认为它比我听过的任何其他话都更能捕捉到我们对被讨厌的厌恶。我们所有人都更爱自己而不是别人，但我们却比在意自己的意见更在意别人的意见。
It is really interesting that the only person who we truly know is ourselves, the only person we are ever going to have a relationship with our whole lives, is ourselves, and yet we let that relationship, we let the love and forgiveness and kindness that we show ourselves be interrupted by the opinions of others who we may never even understand, who quite honestly, it's not our duty to understand. For some of us, that constant concern with being watched or judged is very clinical and it's very chronic. And we can offer up a few explanations as to why. The first is the most severe. That is a social anxiety, disorder. Social anxiety is more than just being shy. It is a constant state of stress and worry
真的很奇怪，我们真正了解的唯一一个人就是我们自己，我们一生中唯一要与之建立关系的唯一一个人就是我们自己，然而我们却让这种关系、让我们对自己展示的爱、宽恕和善良，被那些我们甚至可能永远不会理解的人的意见所打断，说实话，理解他们并不是我们的责任。对我们中的一些人来说，那种对被注视或被评判的持续关注是非常临床且慢性的。我们可以对此给出一些解释。第一种是最严重的。那就是社交焦虑症。社交焦虑不仅仅是害羞。它是一种持续的压力和担忧状态，
towards obtaining the approval of others. And often that leads to a lot of fear. It leads to a lot of avoidance where we might be the subject of criticism, where we might disappoint someone, where we might have to face unknowns, meet new people. And that is derived from an even, I think, deeper fear that we cannot control what other people think about us. And what they think of about us at the end of the day really matters. To a certain extent, I think it does. Other people's opinions are important. And a lot of that is very, very evolutionary. We talk about this a lot on the show because I think it's one of the very foundational principles of social connection, but humans have evolved as a community-based species. In the past, that meant we spent a lot of time
旨在获得他人的认可。这通常会导致大量的恐惧。它会导致大量的回避，比如我们可能会成为批评的对象，我们可能会让某人失望，我们可能会不得不面对未知、结识新的人。这源于一种更深层的恐惧，我认为，那就是我们无法控制别人对我们的看法。而归根结底，别人对我们的看法真的很重要。在某种程度上，我认为确实如此。别人的意见很重要。这其中很大程度上是非常非常进化的结果。我们在节目中经常谈论这一点，因为我认为这是社会联系的最基本原则之一，但人类是作为以社群为基础的物种进化而来的。在过去，这意味着我们花了大量时间
in tribes or groups with the same people that we were exposed to on a daily basis. and our attachment to these groups was necessary for our survival. We found safety in numbers. It was easier to find food to build shelter, to kind of increase our life expectancy. That need to be accepted and part of the group due to its kind of survival benefits is deeply imprinted in our DNA. And historically, if one group didn't like us, if we were rejected or outcast, this meant bad to things. It meant bad things for us. And so we've adapted to treat that threat of social rejection as a real danger. And that is why these days we experience that fear around people not liking us,
与每天接触的同一群人在部落或群体中生活。我们对这些群体的依恋对我们的生存是必要的。我们在人数中找到了安全感。寻找食物、建造住所、提高预期寿命变得更容易。这种由于生存效益而被接受并成为群体一部分的需求，深深地印刻在我们的DNA中。从历史上看，如果一个群体不喜欢我们，如果我们被拒绝或排挤，这意味着糟糕的事情。这对我们来说意味着糟糕的事情。因此，我们已经适应了将社交拒绝的威胁视为真正的危险。这就是为什么今天我们在人们不喜欢我们时会体验到那种恐惧，
especially people who have some kind of social status or power or whose opinion means more to the group. We intrinsically don't want to be disliked. It is simple as that. It creates great discomfort and it's bred by social comparison, it makes us really question our own value. And it also comes down to this idea of reputation. Reputation, honestly great Taylor Swift album, but it's also such a strange concept to me because we don't really know where it comes from. You know, who starts someone's reputation? Like, where does reputation emerge? It's like this collective idea that we have about someone that has no discernible origin and yet it holds so much weight and influence, even on a micro-personal scale. Like, when you meet someone new at a party who you've already heard about from a friend,
尤其是那些具有某种社会地位、权力或其意见对群体意味着更多的人。从本质上讲，我们不想被讨厌。事情就是这么简单。它会带来极大的不适，并且由社会比较所滋生，这让我们真正质疑自己的价值。这也归结为声誉的概念。声誉，老实说泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的一张很棒的专辑，但对我来说这也是一个非常奇怪的概念，因为我们真的不知道它从何而来。你知道的，谁开始了一个人的声誉？比如，声誉是从哪里出现的？这就像是我们对某人的一种集体看法，没有可辨别的起源，然而它却承载着如此巨大的分量和影响力，甚至在微观的个人层面上也是如此。比如，当你在一个派对上遇到一个新的人，你已经从朋友那里听说了他，
and that implicitly means that you already have an opinion of them without even developing it from your own personal experiences. Like, you've never met this person, but an idea of this person precedes them. In the modern day, we worry a lot more about reputation than we previously did. and also in very different ways, because we are very aware that we can be judged at any moment through social media. Obviously, reputation has always kind of somewhat mattered, because it's very symbolic of likeability, of what kind of people think about you. And it was that reputation that would influence life outcomes in a previous generation, when reputation was based on things
这意味着你潜意识里已经对他们有了看法，甚至都没有通过你自己的个人经历来形成这种看法。就像你从未见过这个人，但关于这个人的印象已经先入为主了。在现代，我们比以往任何时候都更担心声誉。而且方式也大不相同，因为我们非常清楚，通过社交媒体，我们在任何时刻都可能遭到评判。显然，声誉在某种程度上一直都很重要，因为它是好感度、别人对你的看法的一种象征。在上一代人中，这种声誉会影响生活结果，当时的声誉是基于诸如
like, you know, purity, holiness, chastity, if you're a woman, and wealth and power if you were a man. And it really often determined your standing in the broader social hierarchy. But that reputation was also usually contained to your small community. So it mattered in that small group, but if you stepped beyond that group, it wasn't as important. Nowadays, we are facing kind of a new reality, a new existence, where really anyone can have an opinion on anyone else who has a digital footprint. And that makes us a lot more aware and attuned to other people's opinions of us through the fact that we can be not just perceived, but judged by others on a very limited amount of information. We live in that age of a constant digital spotlight where those kind of rudimentary primal fears about the opinions of others and social rejection are expanded and exacerbated. and exacerbated daily.
纯洁、圣洁、贞操（如果你是女性），以及财富和权力（如果你是男性）之类的事情。它确实经常决定了你在更广泛的社会等级制度中的地位。但这种声誉通常也局限于你的小社区。所以在那个小群体里它很重要，但如果你超越了那个群体，它就没那么重要了。如今，我们面临着一种新的现实，一种新的存在，在这里，真正任何人都可以对任何拥有数字足迹的人发表看法。这让我们更加意识到并适应别人对我们的看法，因为我们不仅会被感知，还会被他人根据极其有限的信息进行评判。我们生活在那个持续的数字聚光灯的时代，那些关于他人意见和社交被拒的粗浅原始恐惧被放大了，
I think we're also a whole lot more aware in a way of how quickly we can become hated or criticized because of what people choose to say about us online, what people choose to interpret. And that's so unnatural. It's so unnatural to be observed constantly or to feel like you are being observed constantly because there is not a single person in this world who is perfect. There is not a single person who has not made mistakes, but because many of us have grown up online, especially those of us in our 20s,
并且每天都在加剧。我认为在某种程度上，我们也更加意识到，由于人们选择在网上对我们说的话、人们选择如何解读，我们能以多快的速度被讨厌或批评。这太不自然了。不断被观察或者感觉自己一直在被观察，这太不自然了，因为这个世界上没有一个人是完美的。没有一个人没有犯过错误，但因为我们许多人都是在网上长大的，尤其是我们这些二十多岁的人，
those past mistakes are out there for everybody to see, for everybody to think about, for everybody to observe. And we have this like real collective, weird obsession with trying to impose perfection on everybody, but also tear people down for just like the smallest things. So this is kind of all very much leading to my main point. My main point being we are overly concerned based on our psychology, based on our culture, based on our context,
那些过去的错误都在那里，供所有人看到，供所有人思考，供所有人观察。我们有一种真正的集体、奇怪的执念，试图把完美强加给每个人，但也为一些微不足道的事情把人拉下马。所以这一切其实都非常顺应我的核心观点。我的核心观点是：基于我们的心理、基于我们的文化、基于我们的语境，我们过分关注
with other people's opinions, unnaturally so. We want to stay in line. We want to be agreeable. And it's why so many, for so many of us, the smallest negative opinion can send us spiraling. it can cause us to feel like we could potentially become an outcast. It's really interesting when that person, the person who has this negative opinion, the person we're trying to impress is someone that we actually barely know. I have a story for you about this based on when I was back at university. There was this guy, I'm going to call him Damien, and he was kind of like a friend of a friend. He was actually a close friend's roommate.
别人的意见，这种关注很不自然。我们想要保持一致。我们想要讨人喜欢。这就是为什么对我们中的许多人来说，哪怕是最轻微的负面意见也能让我们陷入崩溃的漩涡。它会让我们觉得自己有可能成为局外人。当这个人——那个持有负面意见的人、我们试图去取悦的人——其实是我们几乎不认识的人时，这就非常有趣了。我有一个关于这的故事，基于我还在上大学的时候。有这么个家伙，我叫他达米安（Damien），他有点像是朋友的朋友。实际上他是我的一个好朋友的室友。
I think we talked maybe once or twice, and probably for no longer than five minutes. And yet this guy, for whatever reason, he did not like me. And he made that really clear. And you know what? No matter what anybody else said, no matter how many other people I had in my life who loved me and cared for me and said it didn't matter, I could not stop obsessing over this one person. I could not stop thinking about Damien's opinion. Why is that? Well, I think the best explanation I can offer comes down to perfectionism and how we've been raised.
我想我们大概交谈过一次或两次，时间可能不超过五分钟。然而这家伙，不管出于什么原因，他就是不喜欢我。而且他把这一点表现得很清楚。你知道吗？无论别人怎么说，无论我生命中有多少其他人爱我、关心我说这不重要，我都无法停止对这一个人的执念。我无法停止去想达米安的看法。这是为什么呢？嗯，我认为我能给出的最好解释可以归结为完美主义以及我们的成长方式。
Particularly if you're a woman, we've been raised to be lackable, to be agreeable, to keep the peace. It also stems from a lot of childhood experiences where you want to be a good person. You want people to validate you. You want people to praise you. You want people to include you. If you've been bullied or left out, those early memories, that sense of being excluded, of having someone hate you or being. cruel to you, they have lifelong impacts that leads to a lot of people-pleasing tendencies because we instinctually do not want to feel that emotional pain of rejection ever again. And so we fawn, we appease, we say yes when we should say no, we let people walk all over us because the thing that matters the most is that they like you, that you make them happy
特别是如果你是个女性，我们从小就被教育要讨人喜欢、要随和、要息事宁人。它也源于许多童年经历，那时你想要成为一个好人。你想要别人认可你。你想要别人称赞你。你想要别人包容你。如果你曾被霸凌或冷落，那些早期的记忆、那种被排斥的感觉、那种有人讨厌你或对你残忍的感觉，会对你产生终生的影响，导致许多讨好他人的倾向，因为我们本能地再也不想感受到那种被拒绝的情感痛苦了。于是我们奉承、我们绥靖、我们在该说不的时候说好、我们任由别人践踏我们，因为最重要的事情是他们喜欢你，是你让他们开心，
rather than yourself. And so when someone has a certain opinion or expresses criticism, that makes you feel like in some way you've failed, and it triggers a lot of that historical childhood alarm and fear that once again you are going to be alone or socially rejected. That fear response can come to control us, like I've spoken about, and a secondary consequence for this is that it is increasingly creating a generation of people who are living for others. people like you and I who are living according to what others expect, what other people think is cool, what's trendy, what's acceptable, rather than living according to who they actually want to be.
而不是你自己。所以当某人有某种看法或表达批评时，这会让你觉得自己在某种程度上失败了，并引发了许多历史上的童年警报和恐惧，即你将再次孤独或遭到社会拒绝。正如我所说的那样，这种恐惧反应会开始控制我们，而这带来的一个次要后果是，它越来越多地造就了一代为他人而活的人。像你我这样的人，根据别人的期望、别人认为酷的东西、潮流、可接受的东西来生活，而不是根据他们自己真正想成为的人来生活。
I want to outline exactly what that means, how it really alters our behaviour and the connection that we have to our true selves. I think the first consequence of this need to live for others is conformity. In psychology, conformity really refers to trying to basically fit in or mirror the attitudes, the beliefs, the behaviours of those around us. It's called like the chameleon tendency where depending on who we are with, we blend into our social surroundings by really looking to others to tell us what's normal. Because if we look like them, we act like them, they have no reason to call us out. Because to do so would mean that they would be expressing dislike for themselves. because that is who we are emulating.
我想准确概述这意味着什么，它如何真正改变我们的行为以及我们与真实自我的联系。我认为这种为他人而活的需求带来的第一个后果就是顺从。在心理学中，顺从实际上指的是试图去融入或镜像周围人的态度、信念和行为。这被称为变色龙倾向，即根据我们和谁在一起，我们通过向其他人寻求什么是正常的指引，来融入我们的社交环境。因为如果我们看起来像他们，行为像他们，他们就没有理由指责我们。因为这样做意味着他们会表达对自己的厌恶，
It just really breeds like a thousand clones of the same person. And every day that you wake up and choose to be someone that you think others will accept and like more, you are turning away from your authenticity. You are suppressing your true self. You are unconsciously locking away a part of you that deserves to be seen and deserves to be heard. This is known as self-silencing and that's the need to really suppress our own thoughts. and feelings in order to appease others. This concept was initially only applied to women, but I think it really links to this, it's a lot more universal firstly, and it links to a deeper
因为那是我们在模仿的对象。这实际上只是孕育了成千上万个同一个人的克隆体。每天当你醒来，选择成为一个你认为别人会更能接受和喜欢的人时，你就是在背离你的真实。你是在压抑真实的自己。你无意识地将自己体内一部分应当被看到、应当被听到的一部分锁了起来。这就是所谓的自我消音（self-silencing），即为了安抚他人而真正压抑自己想法和感受的需求。这个概念最初仅适用于女性，但我认为这实际上与此有关，首先它更具普遍性，并且它连接了一个更深层的
idea of self-abandonment. When we self-abandoned or conform in order to be liked, we withhold parts of ourselves in order for others to avoid discomfort with who we are. But in turn, we transfer that discomfort that other people might have with who we are and make ourselves uncomfortable. That is a sad truth. But you know what? When you do that, when you self-abandoned, when you self-silance, you are hurting no one but yourself. Not only can that lead to a deeper sense of very, very real alienation and never really truly knowing who you are. But the longer that we engage in this kind of internal silencing, the harder the habit is to break. It also makes you say things you don't believe, where things you're not comfortable in, make yourself small, and that is a size that you should
自我遗弃的概念。当我们为了被喜欢而自我遗弃或顺从时，我们隐瞒了自己的一部分，以避免别人对我们感到不舒服。但反过来，我们将别人对我们的不舒服转嫁出去，让自己感到不舒服。这是一个悲哀的真相。但你知道吗？当你这样做时，当你自我遗弃、当你自我消音时，你伤害的只有你自己。这不仅会导致一种更深层的、非常非常真实的疏离感，让你永远无法真正了解自己。而且我们进行这种内部消音的时间越长，这个习惯就越难打破。它还会让你说出你不相信的话，让自己陷入不舒服的境地，让自己变得渺小，而这是你
never be, not when life is this short. Additionally, if you pretend to kind of be someone else, you are pretending to be someone you're not, and that will only attract people who are attached to a version of you that isn't real. And so the relationships you form from that fake persona, are going to be inherently artificial. I'm going to bring up another experience that I've had because if you cannot tell, I am definitely someone who is very much trying to embrace the courage to be disliked after for a lot of years
绝不应该有的大小，生活如此短暂，绝不该如此。此外，如果你假装成别人，你是在假装一个并非真实的自己，这只会吸引那些依恋一个虚假版本的你的人。因此，你从这个虚假面具中建立的关系本质上将是虚假的。我要讲另一个我自己的经历，因为如果你看不出来，我绝对是一个在经历了多年对被讨厌的深深恐惧之后，现在非常努力地去拥抱被讨厌的勇气的人。我记得高中时有这么一段时间，我非常努力地假装自己真的很喜欢朋克音乐。比如尖叫核。我不知道。我不知道它叫什么，但就像朋克一样。显然，从我刚刚的描述中你就能看出来。我其实并不喜欢它。我真的不知道自己在做什么。但我想通过假装我们有共同的兴趣来给某些人留下深刻印象，而我认为我当时应该认识到的是，我其实很喜欢泰勒·斯威夫特。我喜欢在学校取得好成绩。我喜欢阅读。我喜欢穿紧身裤。我就是那种女孩。如果我接受了这一点，我就会吸引到更多志同道合的人。也许这意味着我在高中时会有更好的朋友，会有比我最终拥有的那些友谊更充实的关系。我想重点是，当你创造一个外表、一个人设、一个虚假的自我版本，
having a real deep fear of being disliked. I remember this time in high school where I tried so hard to pretend I was really into like punk music. like screamer. I don't know. I don't know what it's called, but it was like punk. Obviously, you can tell from how I just described it. I really didn't like it. I really had no idea what I was doing. But I wanted to impress certain people by pretending that we shared the same interests when what I think I should have recognized was that I really like Taylor Swift. I liked doing well in school. I liked reading. I liked wearing legwomenes. I was that girl. And if I had embraced that, I would have attracted people who were more like-minded. And maybe that would have meant that I had better friends in high school, more fulfilling relationships than the kind of friendships that I did end up having. I guess the point is, is that when you create a facade, a persona, a fake version of yourself
并且你开始相信它时，你周围的人也会开始相信它，这意味着你永远不会在你真正属于的群体中找到归属感。你周围只会环绕着那些并非真正因为“你”而喜欢你的人。他们喜欢的是一个经过精心包装的虚假版本的你。所以，当你开始拥抱被讨厌的勇气时，那自然意味着你会抛弃一些人际关系。人们对你期望中的那个版本以及他们在脑海中创造的你的那个版本有着很深的依恋。我发现，我们看到友谊破裂或关系失败的原因往往是因为人们期望你成为某一个人。他们期望你达到他们对你的期望，
and you begin to believe it, others around you begin to believe it as well, meaning that you are not ever going to feel at place in the groups where you truly belong. You're just going to be surrounded by people who don't genuinely like you for you. They like a curated fake version of yourself. So when you start embracing the courage to be disliked, that is naturally going to mean that you are going to shed a few relationships. People get very attached to the version of you they expect and the version of you that they have created in their minds. I find that so often the reason that we see friendships fall apart or relationships fail is because people expect you to be one person. They expect you to meet their expectations of what they want from you.
而当你决定不再这样做——去说，不，这就是我，我有我自己的意见，我不想总是让你开心，我想做让我开心的事——这些人突然意识到，哦，这个人不会再忍受这一切了。他们不在乎我的意见。正是在那一刻，你能够更清楚地看到
and when you decide to no longer do that to say, no, this is who I am, I've got my own opinions, I don't constantly want to be making you happy, I want to do what makes me happy, these people suddenly realize that like, oh, this person isn't going to put up with this anymore. They don't care about my opinion. It's at that point that you are more clearly able to see
你实际上想过什么样的生活，真实的你想成为什么样的人，以及谁留在你的生命中只是因为你符合他们希望你成为的那种先入为主的概念。我认为失去那些人，甚至被他们讨厌或听到你变了的评价，
what kind of life you would actually love to live, what the true version of you wants. and also who was just in your life because you fit into some preconceived notion of who they wanted you to be. I think that losing those people, perhaps even being disliked by them or hearing that you've changed,
为了获得自我的真正自由，为了获得真实自我的真正自由，这实在是一个微不足道的代价。显然，在某些领域，感知和欣赏他人的意见是必要的。你不会为了反对而反对去冒犯别人，或者变得残酷，或者变成当初让你觉得自己非常渺小的那种人。
is a very small price to pay for the true freedom of the self, the true freedom of the actual self. Obviously there are some areas where a perception and an appreciation of other people's opinions is necessary. You don't want to offend others just for the sake of. it or to be cruel or to turn into one of the people who made you initially feel really small.
但这同时也是一种认识：你的社交圈不仅在改变，而且是有层次和亲疏之分的。优先考虑那些处于核心地位的人，同时忽视那些不在那三个亲密圈子里的人，真的是非常有价值的。所以我可以再多解释一点。我把我的生活尤其是社交生活想象成四个圆圈。每个圆圈都在前一个圆圈之外扩展，变得越来越大。你在中间。你是最重要的圆圈。然后是家人、挚友、你的伴侣、偶尔见面的朋友、或许还有同事、泛泛之交，最后只是像陌生人，其中也包括那些可能不喜欢你的人。最亲密的
But it's also about realizing that your social circle not only changes but has layers and levels of closeness. And prioritizing those that are more central by whilst, you know, kind of disregarding those who aren't in those close three circles is really, really, really valuable. So I might explain this a little bit more. I visualize my kind of life and my social life in particular like four circles. Each circle kind of expanding just beyond the last circle, getting larger and larger. You're in the middle. You're the most important circle. Then comes family, close friends, your partner, friends you see every now and again, maybe co-workers, acquaintances, and then finally just like strangers and included in that are people who might not like you. The closest
三个圆圈，包括你、你的家人、你爱的人，才是全部重要的。这些人的意见才是唯一重要的意见，因为它们是相互支持的，因为这些人爱你。他们并不是想把你拉下马。所以当我们再次想到，你知道的，被讨厌的勇气。如果那个让你担忧其意见的人超出了这三个圆圈，那就没有必要听他们的。因为如果你明天真的病得很重，如果发生了什么可怕的事，他们不会是那个坐在你身边支持你的人。所以在你春风得意的时候，你也不配听他们的。我知道把这些人切断、无视他们的意见、在某种程度上忽略他们说起来容易
three circles including you, your family, your loved ones, they are all that matter. The opinions of those people are the only ones that matter because they are mutually supportive because these people love you. They're not trying to tear you down. So when we think about, you know, once again, the courage to be disliked. If the person whose opinion you are worried about sits beyond those three circles, there is no point listening to them. Because if you were to become really ill tomorrow, if something terrible was to happen, they would not be the one sitting there by your side supporting you. So in your good times, you don't deserve to listen to them either. I know that cutting those people out, disregarding their opinion, ignoring them in some ways, is easier said than
做起来难，因为正如我们所描述的那样，他人的意见有一种非常微妙的方式，在非常无意识的层面上影响我们的行为。那么我们如何摆脱这种压力呢？你知道的，很显然，关心别人的想法是非常生物性的、非常进化的、非常原始的。那么我们需要对自己说些什么呢？当这种自我意识悄然而至，并威胁到我们，让我们受制于那些A不在乎你、B无关紧要的别人的意见时，我们该怎么做？在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论拥抱被讨厌勇气的四种方法。《2%》。
done because often, as we've described, the opinions of others have this very subtle way of influencing our behaviours on a very unconscious level. So how do we escape that pressure? You know, obviously this is very bio, like very evolutionary, very primal to care about what other people think. So what do we need to tell ourselves? What do we need to do when that self-consciousness kind of sneaks in and threatens to keep us at the behest of the opinions of others who, A, don't care about you, and B, don't matter. Well, we are going to discuss the four ways that you can embrace the courage to be disliked after this short break. 2%.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWO%。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟小金有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过那段时光的。其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier, person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆到了台面上，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的心理治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太正确了。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah, for me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so right.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。欢迎在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或其他您收听播客的平台收听回放。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你们最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某个目标时，我们往往会全神贯注。
wrapped up in the chase, that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
完全沉浸在追逐中，以至于我们没有意识到自己已经拥有了那件东西。我们却仍在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，既然你们觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要，那你们是因为害怕才做一个好人吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations. about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
绝对是的。这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。欢迎来到我克尔·盖恩斯的新播客《以防万一》，我们将在这里就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《以防万一》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律诉讼战，旨在证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱平（Greg Lepin）和迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There are four things that I want you to remember when it comes to being disliked. Number one, not everyone is going to like you, and that is something that you can't change. But number two, you are. are never going to be criticized by someone who is doing better than you. Thirdly, often someone else's dislike or negative judgments are really a projection of their own insecurities. And finally, we can use their criticism, their dislike, as fuel for our advantage, as motivation. There is quite literally
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。当谈到不被人喜欢时，我想让你记住四件事。第一，不是每个人都会喜欢你，这是你无法改变的。但第二，你永远不会受到一个比你过得好的人的批评。第三，通常别人对你的不喜欢或负面评价，实际上是他们自身不安全感的投射。最后，我们可以把他们的批评、他们的不喜欢当作对我们有利的燃料，化作动力。
nothing more inspiring and motivating than someone telling you that you can't do something, or someone trying to bring you down or who is not comfortable with your success, who feels the need to criticize you. Because implicitly, when that happens, we now feel like we have something to prove. And that is like actually such a motivating force. It's also that in that moment, we become a lot better with embracing the courage to be disliked because we realize that other people's opinions or appraisals of you, as I've said before, have a lot more to do with them than us. You can read any comment section on YouTube or TikTok or Instagram and you will see hundreds of people ready to say anything that's going to bring someone down, especially people who are doing
没有什么比别人对你说你做不到某事，或者有人试图打压你、对你的成功感到不自在、觉得有必要批评你更具有启发性和激励作用的了。因为潜意识里，当这种情况发生时，我们现在会觉得我们有什么东西需要证明。这实际上是一种非常强大的激励力量。这也是因为在那一刻，我们变得更能拥抱“被讨厌的勇气”，因为我们意识到，正如我以前所说的那样，别人的意见或对你的评价，很大程度上与他们有关，而不是与我们有关。你可以在 YouTube、TikTok 或 Instagram 上的任何评论区看到数百人准备说任何可以把别人踩下去的话，尤其是那些过好
their own shit, who are in their own lane, who are confident, who know what their life is about. and you know what the common denominator is in those situations? It's not the person on the receiving end. It's not the content that they make. It is these people, this group of people, who are unhappy with themselves and who feel the need to pull others down because it gives them a mental and emotional boost.
自己的生活、走自己的路、充满自信、知道自己的人生意义何在的人。你知道在这些情况下共同点是什么吗？不是接受批评的那个人。不是他们制作的内容。而是这些少数人、这群对自身不满意、觉得有必要把别人拉下来以获得心理和情感提升的人。
So it's really interesting because they've started doing studies on this, particularly around trolling and kind of cyberbullying. And this recent study that was published in the cybercyclical Journal, it found that people with lower self-esteem are more likely to engage in activities like internet trolling than anybody else. And the people who do that, those traits are also more associated with psychopathy and with receiving pleasure from the distress and take down of others. And that is such a them problem. That has nothing to do with you. The same goes for real-life interactions. Obviously, we're talking about like a social media space here. But let's think
所以这真的很有趣，因为他们已经开始对此进行研究，特别是围绕网络水军和网络欺凌。最近发表在《网络心理学》杂志上的一项研究发现，自尊心较低的人比其他人更有可能参与网络水军等活动。而那些这样做的人，这些特质也更多地与心理变态以及从他人的痛苦和垮台中获得快乐联系在一起。这完全是他们自身的问题。这与你无关。现实生活中的互动也是如此。显然，我们在这里谈论的是社交媒体空间。但让我们想一想
about my old friend Damien, my old university friend Damien. There is something deeper in that person's psychology that leads them to these kind of pathological chronic takedowns. And the worst thing we can do is actually believe that the opinions of these people matter. When I think about him, I'm like, he had only really met me twice. What was it about them that gave them such kind of a sick obsession fascination with making me feel bad about myself. Because I'm pretty sure that as soon as I moved on, he found someone else to project that hate to. I know it's a classic quote, but like Michelle Obama, boss lady, she always says it. When they go low, we go high.
我老朋友达米安，我的大学老朋友达米安。那个人的心理深处有些东西导致了他们这种病态的、长期的打压行为。而我们能做的最糟糕的事情，其实就是去相信这些人的意见很重要。每当我想起他时，我就觉得，他其实只见过我两次。究竟是什么让他们对让我对自己的感觉变糟产生了一种病态的执念和迷恋？因为我很确信，一旦我向前看，他就会找到其他人来投射这种仇恨。我知道这是一句经典名言，但就像米歇尔·奥巴马，这位女老板，她总是说的那样：当他们走低时，我们走高。
So not only does that give you a much needed self-esteem boost to look at that situation and go, okay, the reason this person has this opinion probably has nothing to do with me and everything to do with the fact that they are not happy with themselves. But these individuals have much bigger problems than their opinion about you. And if they have something to say, that probably means you're doing something right. This is where I really want to introduce this concept called Tall Poppy Syndrome that is really common in Australia. So in Australia, Tall Poppy Syndrome is this idea that the best flowers, the tallest flowers, the ones that bloom the first, are also the first to be cut down. And that analogy applies to our lives. The people who shine the brightest, the people who are least
因此，这不仅能给你急需的自尊心提升，让你审视这种情况并说：“好吧，这个人持有这种观点的原因可能与我无关，而完全与他们对自己不满意这一事实有关。”而且这些家伙有着比他们对你的看法大得多的问题。如果他们有什么话要说，那可能意味着你做对了什么。在这里，我真的很想引入一个叫做“高罂粟花综合症”的概念，这在澳大利亚非常普遍。所以在澳大利亚，“高罂粟花综合症”是指这样一种观点：最好的花、长得最高的花、最早盛开的花，也是最先被砍倒的花。这个比喻同样适用于我们的生活。那些闪耀得最亮的人，那些最不
afraid to be themselves, who shoot up, who are successful, who are confident, they are always going to be the first ones who are targeted with takedowns. And it's so frustrating. But what we realize is that in those moments, you are the tallest flower in the field. You are the tall poppy. That is why you are receiving their resentment from others. Once again, you are never going to be judged by someone who is doing better than you because they are probably already secure in themselves. They know what it's like to be in your position. They want you to succeed. And they know their worth without needing to compare or tear you down. And those are the people that you should surround yourself with when you are embracing that courage to be disliked. The difference these people make in your life is incredible. I've seen it myself.
害怕做自己的人，那些脱颖而出、取得成功、充满自信的人，总是会成为首先被攻击的目标。这太令人沮丧了。但我们意识到，在那些时刻，你是田野里最高的花。你是那株高罂粟花。这就是为什么你会招致别人的怨恨。再说一次，你永远不会被一个比你过得更好的人评判，因为他们可能已经在内心感到踏实。他们知道处于你的位置是什么感觉。他们希望你成功。他们不需要通过比较或贬低你来证明自己的价值。当你拥抱那种被讨厌的勇气时，这些就是你应该与之交往的人。这些人对你生活的影响是不可思议的。我亲眼见证过。
I've really been on this journey of kind of realizing that if I want to grow further, if I want to be a better version of myself, I have to be pickier about the people I choose to spend my time around. And that doesn't necessarily mean meeting people and being like, no, you can't be my friend. But more so being like, okay, if I want this inner circle, I want to make sure these people are making me feel good about myself. And so I've really been surrounding myself with women who want nothing but success for those around them, who collaborate, who lift each other up. And it's something I'm so grateful for for so long, I really prioritized hanging out, socializing, interacting with people who didn't like me because I had this compulsion to make them like me. That was like the biggest prize. But now I've
我确实一直在经历这样一段旅程：我逐渐意识到，如果我想进一步成长，如果我想成为更好的自己，我必须对选择与之共度时光的人更加挑剔。这并不一定意味着遇到某人时心里想“不，你不能做我的朋友”。而是更倾向于觉得：“好吧，如果我想拥有这个核心朋友圈，我要确保这些人能让我对自己的感觉良好。”因此，我真的让自己身边的女性都只希望周围的人成功，她们会合作、会互相激励。这是我非常感激的一点。很长一段时间里，我真的优先把时间和精力花在那些不喜欢我的人身上，和他们社交、互动，因为我有一种强烈的冲动，想让他们喜欢我。这就像是最大的奖赏。但现在我
started really protecting the relationships that bring me joy and the relationships with people who, not that they won't criticize me, not that they won't call me out, but who are willing to just be in my corner. Alongside that, I think it's also important to be okay with the fact that you're not going to be everybody's cup of tea and not being everybody's cup of tea also involves gradually removing and reducing our emotional reliance on the validation of others. So psychologists generally identify two sources of validation, external validation, which comes from the acknowledgement of others, and internal validation, which comes from our own positive attributes, positive self-beliefs, strengths, and achievements. When we rely on external validation, often this has come from
开始真正保护那些给我带来快乐的人际关系，以及与那些人的人际关系——并不是说他们不会批评我，不是说他们不会指出我的错误，而是那些愿意坚定地站在我身后的人。除此之外，我认为同样重要的是要接受这样一个事实：你不可能成为所有人的茶，而不再做所有人的茶也意味着逐渐消除和减少我们对他人认可的情感依赖。心理学家通常将认可分为两种来源：外部认可，来自于他人的承认；内部认可，来自于我们自身的积极特质、积极的自我信念、优势和成就。当我们依赖外部认可时，这通常源于
us being gradually trained to do that, especially in the kind of educational environment. that we have been raised in, where we want the praise, we want the approval of other people. We seek the admiration of those we see as better than us. However, if you constantly look to external approval for your self-worth, your self-worth is never going to be stable because the opinions of others are not consistent or reliable. They are fickle because humans are fickle. and it's only going to take one small comment, one small feeling of rejection, one small moment to completely destroy your self-worth because it is bound up in the actions of people and the thoughts of people who you cannot control, who you have no say in.
我们逐渐被训练成这样，尤其是在我们所受的教育环境中，我们渴望得到赞扬，渴望得到别人的认可。我们寻求那些我们视为比我们优秀的人的赞赏。然而，如果你不断从外部的赞许中寻找自我价值，你的自我价值将永远不会稳定，因为别人的意见既不一致也不可靠。它们是变化无常的，因为人类就是变化无常的。只要一个小小的评论，一个小小的被拒绝的感觉，一个小小的时刻，就足以彻底摧毁你的自我价值，因为它与那些你无法控制、你没有发言权的人的行为和思想紧密相连。
So I want you to ask yourself, what is it that you like about yourself that has absolutely no attachment to others? What do you like about yourself that people would maybe be surprised to know? like it's a little private secret source of self-love. It could be that you feel really intense joy towards like the smallest things, that you like people watching or that you're creative. It might be that your dreams are really interesting, that you love very deeply, that you are dedicated to your goals,
所以我想让你问问自己：关于你自己，有什么是与他人毫无关联的，是你自己真正喜欢的？你身上有什么特质，如果别人知道了可能会感到惊讶？就像是一个私密的自我之爱的秘密源泉。可能是你对最微小的事物也能感受到强烈喜悦，可能是你喜欢观察人群，或者你很有创造力。也可能是你的梦想非常有趣，你爱得很深，你对目标充满执着，
that you are spiritual, that you have a great music taste, that you have some secret special talent, private things about yourself that you love. And reinforce those things above, all else, remind yourself of them as much as you can, and go on to cultivate them even more. When you are so focused on what you bring to the world, how amazing you are, you become this impenetrable force of self-love. I also like to imagine when I really feel the need to please certain people or to make them like me, I imagine this big golden bubble, experience.
你富有灵性，你有着极好的音乐品味，你拥有某种秘密的特殊才能，那些你所热爱的关于你自己的私密事物。把这些事情放在首位，尽可能多地提醒自己这些，并去进一步培养它们。当你如此专注于你为世界带来的是什么、你是多么惊艳时，你就会变成一股坚不可摧的自爱力量。当我有强烈冲动去取悦某些人或让他们喜欢我时，我也喜欢想象这样一个巨大的金色气泡，这个体验
banding out from my heart that surrounds me, that protects me, that makes me magnetic. And it kind of goes on to engulf everybody else and make them feel like they can also be authentic and true in my presence. It's like these visualization exercises, this golden bubble, allows me to escape my anxiety by really focusing on a comforting, you know, comforting mental imagery. This tool has been so powerful for me. It makes me so confident. Like, it's like a protective shield against other people's judgments where I can acknowledge that maybe someone's looking at my outfit and going like, oh, I don't like that, or someone I've met once has a bad impression of me or anything. But that doesn't matter. It just bounces off me. I'm in my golden
从我的心脏向外扩张，包围着我、保护着我，让我充满吸引力。它甚至会吞没其他人，让他们觉得在我的面前也能做真实、坦诚的自己。就像这些视觉化练习一样，这个金色气泡让我通过真正专注于舒适的、你知道的舒适心理意象来逃避焦虑。这个工具对我太有用了。它让我如此自信。就像是一个抵御他人评判的防护盾，我可以承认也许有人在看我的穿搭然后觉得“哦，我不喜欢那个”，或者我见过一次面的人对我有不好的印象之类的。但这并不重要。它只是从我身上弹开。我正处于我的金色
bubble. I also want to say one final reminder. Each day, each moment, you are presented with the opportunity to be your best self. And you can either choose to live authentically, and passionately and in your own power, or you can choose to mask that version of you. You can choose to minimize your goals, your values, your passion, your identity, because you're scared of what other people think. It is your responsibility to choose which version you want to be.
气泡中。我还想给出最后一点提醒。每一天，每一个时刻，你都面临着成为最好的自己的机遇。你要么选择真实、充满激情并活在自己的力量中，要么选择掩盖那个版本的自己。你可以选择缩小你的目标、你的价值观、你的热情、你的身份，因为你害怕别人怎么想。选择成为哪个版本是你的责任。
Not anybody else's, not your family, not your friends, only you. So visualize that version of you, that version of you that doesn't care what people think, that doesn't care of people don't agree with what they're doing because they believe in it, who doesn't care if people like what they wear, doesn't care if people think they look trendy, doesn't care if people have some weird negative opinion of them,
不是别人的，不是你家人的，不是你朋友的，只有你。所以去想象那个版本的自己，那个不在乎别人怎么想、不在乎别人是否不同意他们所做的事（因为他们坚信不疑）、不在乎别人是否喜欢他们穿什么、不在乎别人是否觉得他们赶时髦、不在乎别人对他们有什么奇怪负面看法的自己，
because they love themselves. And watch yourself become that version. Imagine speaking to that version. Act from a place of that version of yourself. Ask yourself, in moments where you are trying to be more like, or trying to make other people like you more, what would that version of you do? What would that authentic version of you say?
因为他们深爱着自己。看着自己成为那个版本。试着与那个版本的自己对话。从那个版本的自己的立场出发去行动。问问自己：在那些你试图表现得更好、或者试图让别人更喜欢你的时刻，那个版本的你会怎么做？那个真实的你会说些什么？
How would they act in this situation? I was saying this to a friend the other day, but it's also really impossible to criticize or have anything negative to say about someone who is just so clearly knows who the fuck they are, who is just so clearly embodying their authentic self. We all know those people, we see those people, so you should become that person.
在这种情况下他们会怎么做？我前几天对一个朋友说过这话，但对于那些非常清楚自己是谁、非常明显地在体现真实自我的人，批评他们或对他们说任何消极的话其实是不可能的。我们都知道这样的人，我们都见过这样的人，所以你也应该成为那样的人。
by embracing the fact that not everybody is going to like you, and that is totally okay. In fact, it's probably a good sign. It's probably beneficial. Because like we said before, it means you're doing something right. It means they've never seen anybody like you before. It means that you are so comfortable in your own power that this person's opinion cannot harm you. The world is so small, life is so short. You are just kind of a grain of sand in the universe, and you're living amongst a million billion, billion other grains of sand. So it doesn't need to be that meaningful. Someone else's
去拥抱“并不是每个人都会喜欢你”这个事实，这完全没问题。事实上，这可能是一个好兆头。这可能是有益的。因为正如我们之前所说，这意味着你做对了什么。这意味着他们以前从未见过像你这样的人。这意味着你在自己的力量中感到如此自在，以至于这个人的意见无法伤害你。世界如此之小，生命如此短暂。你只是宇宙中的一粒沙子，生活在成千上万亿粒其他沙子之中。所以它没必要那么有意义。别人的
opinion doesn't need to ruin your day. Doesn't need to ruin your life. Because when you hold onto something that has slipped out of someone's mouth, something that someone has said behind your back, something that has come through the grapevine, that's not ruining their day. Thinking about it more isn't hurting them. It's hurting you. And so you have to make a choice of like, am I going to continue you're thinking about this or am I going to realize that the only people's opinions that matter to me are my own and the people who I love. I think that's a really beautiful place to end it. And I want to thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I know it was quite rambly. I know it was quite philosophical, maybe less psychological. But I really cannot state it enough.
意见不需要毁了你的一天。不需要毁了你的生活。因为当你紧抓着从某人嘴里溜出的话、某人在你背后说的话、从小道消息传来的话不放时，那并没有毁了他们的一天。多想一想并没有伤害他们。它伤害的是你。所以你必须做出选择：我是要继续想这件事，还是我要意识到，对我唯一重要的意见只有我自己的，以及我所爱之人的意见。我想这是一个非常完美的结束语。非常感谢你收听今天的节目。我知道这有些东拉西扯。我知道这很哲学，也许心理学色彩没那么浓厚。但我真的怎么强调都不为过。
That book was amazing. It's really changed my mind on so many things and really opened my eyes to the fact that I think I've spent a lot of my life caring about what other people think and I don't want to care about it anymore. And I think that when I've started to adopt that philosophy, it's made me a much better person, a much more powerful person, a much happier person to just be more secure in who I am. So I hope that, I really, yeah, I hope that's something that you can find as well for every single one of you listening. If you enjoyed this episode, as always, please feel free to share it with someone who you think might enjoy it as well or leave a five-star review. It really helps the show to grow and reach new people.
那本书太棒了。它真的改变了我对很多事情的看法，也真正让我大开眼界：我意识到自己前半生花了很多时间去在意别人的想法，而我再也不想在意了。我认为，当我开始采纳这种哲学时，它让我成为了一个更好的人、一个更有力量的人、一个对自己身份更加笃定而更快乐的人。所以我希望，我真的、是的，我希望正在收听节目的每一个人也能找到属于自己的这份笃定。如果你喜欢这期节目，一如既往地，请随时把它分享给你认为也会喜欢它的人，或者留下一个五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众很有帮助。
If you don't already, you can follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. We are currently taking episode suggestions for 2024. So if there's something going on in your life, going on in your 20s, and you want to understand it more, you want to know what's going on, please feel free to send it to me over there. And we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
如果你还没有关注我们，可以在 Instagram 上关注 @That Psychology Podcast。我们目前正在接受 2024 年的节目主题建议。所以如果你生活中遇到了什么事，或者正经历二十多岁的迷茫，想要更多地了解它、想知道是怎么回事，请随时通过那边发消息给我。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）主持的《以防万一》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
这个空间关乎黑人群体的男性经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全、却需要坦诚相待的对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界释放出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以防万一》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，莱平。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you will come up. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和构建韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦。你就会破茧成蝶。迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO percent，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。